hi there reject nation I'm Greg I'm John
we are going to check out this trailer
you know considering III is going on and
you Val how official siege trail uh this
was sent to us by the team at Black Rose
Arts shout out to the man Andrew over
there there are a small development team
only twelve people they spend a lot of
time on this so I'm excited to check it
out they paid us forty thousand dollars
to watch this trail oh yeah all from
their indiegogo just going straight to
us so make sure to contribute to their
IndieGoGo because the more contributions
they get right back into our pocket we
second patreon seriously these guys are
cool and this video eight hundred thirty
thousand views and getting a very very
positive response so we were like
alright let's check this out
[Music]
Severus Humphries that fighting to
survive to all of you fighting battles
along remember our ancestors in the
harsh wilderness
[Music]
nice come on
good I'm sort of liking
battling the naysayers that are
frightened to them without hope to
survive and not let go of words and
hopelessness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's
rather get out there and hunt it down
nice hmm hey guys this is Black Rose
Arts we are a small fully guided team
working day and night in crunch mode
when our communities and our dream
Viking pal all named anglicized from Old
Norse is now in the beginning of its
journey this is important to understand
what we are making 9 worlds of Viking
mythology combined with great combat and
multiplayer battles we're very excited
about the depth of the Norse mythology
and why developing the world in the best
way at this stage all our budget stems
and crowdfunding the some of which you
can check with yourself on our IndieGoGo
page we work on to launch the first our
clothes test last summer but were
delayed by server problems doesn't help
it's all we realize that I had to keep
the quality of work and want to show to
the world as such we continued the
development process and our loyal
backers supporting us thank you guys you
can take a look at our very first
trailers or old dead blocks to compare
our progress with the current content a
lot see where we are going now we're
working at the most important part of
our journey
combat system 2.0 oh yeah make sure in
the beta text is keep in mind that while
some of the shown mechanics are
implemented some are still not finished
and aren't representative of their final
game State now our game is about Vikings
and the new combat is designed to fit
this theme first of all that means if
focus is on dynamic and free combat with
the left mouse button you can perform
different sweeping attacks according to
the direction you move your mouse not
only the angle but the type of attack
itself will be completely at your
control calls states come on back more
diverse these cycled weapon has its own
optimal distance the whole can be played
from anniversa third-person perspective
we aim to achieve a set of animations
that looks accurate and immersive for
the Viking period and control as well as
well all reading is great however
dynamic dodging in any direction can
give you even more options to win the
battle and it proves to be an even more
effective strategy to die press any move
button and the Dodge button
simultaneously you will expend a certain
amount of stamina however it can help
you to a 40% of your stamina because the
dodging is are extremely strong and
agile warriors obviously games sliding
mechanics to your advantage as to break
up your attacks to catch your opponent
off guard
Vikings mostly used long bows and as you
might expect they didn't have any
crosshairs to help them along there will
be no crosshair is available for bows
above all only your bow your arrow and
the interviews I'll strength and
distance your arrow flies which is also
determined by the amount and pull back
your bowstring there is an automatic
breath folder it will start when you
stop moving for two seconds and after
five seconds of staying still the bowl
will stop swinging all these features
suggests way no crosshairs the first
person camera view we're thought over
after we've received your feedback in
our initial trailers since a big part of
the community and expressed concerns
about using the
the cast we decided to improvers the
realism of archery about holes and make
it more hard for and realistic
experience archery is well underway and
the movie showed before there won't be a
problem with third person Peterson bow
holes during any competitive multiplayer
game which supports both cameras this
decision will let you focus on each
battle without needing to worry about
who's hiding behind the wall make the
game work fair in general we are aiming
to provide emergent minimalistic HUD to
allow you to focus on the battle
unfolding before tea in this video the
HUD has been removed entirely for the
sake of cinematics being able to control
your stamina and energy levels is
paramount to your success in battle as
for stamina drains your movements will
be slow less effective sometimes we face
situations when your opponents try to
run away from battles eluding you your
hard-earned victory to combat this we
have decided that the best way to deal
with such cases will be to tie speed and
health together lower the health but
lower the speed the funding we have
received immediately goes into us
bringing the game closer and closer to
the point all of us want to see it what
do you eat them being a bathroom you're
making the contribution that sharing
becomes an integral part of the future
of the game they keep our community
updated on the improvements we make and
the changes that we plan to implement as
much as we can
now our game is to build a strong
relationship with our backers we have
implemented several forms of
communication primarily using the
interactive development board to see the
game players want to come to fruition if
you check our IndieGoGo page updates you
see that it works you frequently ask for
community opinion via a number of short
routes and falls in the discord but
you're often about gameplay features for
example some time ago the community
decided to remove the arrow camera
feature and even remove the horns from
all standard Thomas Hauk communities
request we're launching our alpha test
under a nondisclosure agreement
it's very important to know we have
chosen to do this as an answer to the
request on part of our backers our
position is set we will not release to
the public anything less than a Polish
man we don't want to rush it
however we respect our community and
decided to let the backers who become a
part of the development process who
wants to try out the game many state do
that only under NDA right now please
keep in mind this output is absolutely
not have a lot the players Grif is first
knife cutter sharing the old ever
telling me what matters who are
interested about any state about home
check out the sandbox mode while we're
still working on beta we never intended
to release or so V alpha and it wasn't
including the perks descriptions of
IndieGoGo we have given it to everyone
with access to the beta for free just
friendly warning however the current
alpha build is too early and hardly
playable if you want to get a great
first impression
we recommend waiting till the beta test
launch the date for the beta launch in a
state we're preparing now is not set yet
way made the schedule fairly flexible it
can take one and a half week and three
months meanwhile we and our backers
understand the purpose of the Alpha will
be testing some features from beta and
adding them to the sandbox to speed up
the development of Bell Hall we utilize
some third-party assets for example you
are using high quality photo scanned
models which make photo realism possible
in real time what you see is running
with very high FPS on the gaming
computer battle royale mode has less
graphics detail for sake of the
optimization but still looks pretty good
cable up settings for low-end pcs as
well now Hall is not a pay2win game
however there are cosmetics which will
allow you to look like a boss on the map
these items will never give you an
unfair advantage and are purely cosmetic
we pay a lot of attention to the details
for items
many of them are forged by the artists
for the best
morbid blacksmith from knee level ear
the Battle Royale setting in Valhalla
makes sense here brave warriors fight
for whole eternity since we set out a
map in the afterlife dying doesn't
actually cost you anything and the
respawn mechanic will be well integrated
to the war within the Biff cross what is
more eccentric old appear first as the
warm-up mode your spirit will move
organically to the big rig battlefield
more information about it will be
available in our next movie gogo updates
feel free to share your suggestions with
us via our interactive desk and discord
server while we're finishing up a new
combat system we have a great
opportunity to become a part of our
Viking family during its early stages
between its a lot of cool bonuses to
being one of the amazing people who
makes the whole come to life skull
oh snap oh they're gonna have some
dragon Yi's Daenerys is coming that's
her Narus is coming drogon is not gonna
kill who he should but instead burn
chair well it's great for such early
stages of a video game mm-hm independent
company putting this bad boy together
all through crowdfunding that's very
impressive what they've done yeah
definitely I've seen worse I've seen a
lot worse that's really good absolutely
name good stuff that's dropping two
consoles the Dozen one and even though
not all of the graphics are obviously
done and everything there were some of
those moments especially out in the
forest were like the motions of the
camera with your character and the
backgrounds and stuff especially when
they brought up the forest in the way
they had like photorealistic backgrounds
they can move in real time like I
thought that really came through
I like their attention to detail in
terms of making sure you're living in
this not just world but the lore as well
it's not all gonna be realistic in to a
certain degree me tease a dragon at the
end of this to talk about the realms the
mythology of it also integrating some of
the mythos but it's taking as much
historical accuracy as possible in terms
of environment what the limitations were
like when they were specifying the bow
and arrow usage I like the combination
of like detail on how human body would
essentially work with the speed if
you're if you're health as though your
speed is lower with stamina I wish we
covered a little bit of rations how you
eat I'm always fascinated by that and if
you have yeah said they said it's in the
afterlife but is there an ability to
heal yourself if you don't have like a
critical injury or something making sure
the gameplay feels authentic as if you
are an actual Viking member the violence
looks really cool i love the specific
dynamics you can do per weapon how each
one's gonna be a different kind of
movement it's not all gonna just feel
like the same thing this is a PC yeah I
get that least first and foremost I
don't know if it'll pour it out to any
place else but PC for the start yet yeah
that's really cool it's awesome it lets
get early access to it too oh yeah well
and I love just the idea I mean you know
video games are more popular than ever
and it seems the
relationship that they're able to
cultivate with the people who are really
into this game and into the potential
for it is cool because you know it seems
like they truly do have their own
independent operation with their own
kind of market testing abilities yeah
they're IndieGoGo taking feedback like
that's inspiring to me because a game is
such a huge undertaking and oftentimes a
big purchase - you have like an actual
dialogue with the people are gonna be
spending all that time in your game yeah
it seems like a pretty cool thing and it
seems at least from what they've laid
out here like it's gonna help the game
to be as good as it can be yeah man I
got rid of those [ __ ] horns yeah what
gives man shitty horn don't lead with
the horns what kind of cosmetic upgrades
what kind of game do you think we're
trying to play here I want the [ __ ]
horns yeah plus you know I love the
mythology angle and I like the
historical angle - there's an obvious
little inkling of like anytime you go
back into historical times and you go
into history you think of Assassin's
Creed but nice to have another game
where you can explore that in a
different setting with a different tonal
aesthetic compatibility I know this is B
pitches a battle royale I would like it
if they can up there and change
everything you're doing and implement
implement like some type of story
campaign mode I want to set up a village
I want to raise a family
I want to fight anybody as a Viking I
just want to be a Viking settler can I
find Minnesota the great thing about
this game of like why I'm asking for
things to be a part of it is because
there's so much potential for this to be
something that can truly be a bit of a
landmark for an independent video game
this totally can lend itself to some
kind of really cool story I mean
especially if you have like a show like
Vikings people loved chose like Game of
Thrones which I know is that Vikings
territory but Ward's yeah and on ships
and everything but who's the arrow okay
he can't customize characters yeah oh
yeah I feel like there's so many options
you can do this I'm excited for this
this seems like it could be a lot of fun
actually yeah man and also I mean just
as a small thing I love that you can
shift between first and third person POV
because that ability in any game like
this combat based game is a lifesaver
all right guys well there's a link in
the description box to their IndieGoGo
page there's a link in description box
to watch this whole video trailers last
pitch in full screen
please do that as soon as you can you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification about let us
know what you think about this footage
and I'll catch you guys soon